let's eliminate those excuses take
ownership of your freakin life
fails cures all lots of companies come
in and say I have a great idea or I have
a company and we've got some sales but
we only need to do this and we only need
to do that and you talk to them and you
talk to the entrepreneur and I'm like
why aren't you selling I'm in the belief
system for me and my journey to start
small think big and scale fast want to
be happy build a life not a business
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn some of the best advice
some entrepreneurs featured on HBO's hit
show billions let's kick it off with
rule number one take ownership with
Jocko willing on social media I see this
a lot guys will hit me up girls will hit
me up something went wrong with a client
I stepped in I took ownership they
thanked me problem solved
got it squared away I can't people are
surprised people are surprised that it
works people are surprised that it works
and again just to make sure everybody
knows that alone doesn't work you still
have to problem solve the problem
without you cause with the client right
right
you-you-you gave them what they needed
late or it's gonna be late and now you
say it's my fault that doesn't mean that
you don't need to get it to em ASAP and
make up some corrective measures and
lower the price to do something so that
it makes up for the problem but the
worst thing you can say is well you
specify exactly what you wanted in the
order and therefore we couldn't get you
what you wanted on time okay we're never
coming back for business skin and we're
hangry this whole time and I'm gonna
short you money when we pay you in
anyways if I pay you at all the next
time you get into a situation and you
write down you techniques the excuses
and the reasons that you come up with
look at them and then figure out how
they were how those things were actually
your fault and/or how you could have
prevented them because a lot of times
it's like here's here's here's one hey
boss we didn't get the mission
accomplished because the weather rolled
in and we couldn't launch on the mission
that's that's the problem now we all
know that we don't control the weather
so when you will you write the problem
down we failed the mission because we
didn't control the weather we can't
control the weather that's why we failed
the mission that's my excuse that's a
that's a logical reason there's that's
that's a that's a legitimate excuse but
don't use it what you do is you say what
could I have done to have controlled the
weather okay I don't Capcom okay wait I
can't control the weather what could I
have done I could have come up with a
contingent
see plan I could have come up we could
have staged in a better place so then
you go to the boss and you say look boss
here's what happened the weather went
south really bad that was a problem but
it's a problem that I should have done a
better job taking care of what I should
have done was I should had a contingency
plan
I should have staged closer to the
target area that I could have taken
vehicles instead of helicopters that's
my fault
from now on I will absolutely have a
secondary plan this won't happen again
we can't control the weather but we can
control how we plan and how we execute
and this won't happen again
there you go so you take the most
outrageous thing that you know you can't
control you figure out a way to control
it and you take ownership of that thing
and it is gonna it's gonna make your
life so much better and by the way the
next time you have a mission and you
plan that contingency and you actually
execute and implement what you said
you're gonna do guess what you will
accomplish the mission there's a whole
part of ownership that preempts the
problem if you've got someone that knows
if I know that I can make an excuse if I
know that I can make an excuse then
guess what I'm not gonna set things up
properly if I don't set things up
properly mmm more often or more often
than the other way I will fail to do
execute what I'm supposed to execute if
you have an excuse right same same thing
with you as an individual human being if
you as an individual human being if you
got some excuses that you can throw out
there that you can say I had no control
over that then you know what you say
okay what are my contingency plans what
could I have planned differently let's
eliminate those excuses take ownership
of your freaking life
rule number two break your thinking
patterns with Tim Ferriss what if I did
the opposite for 48 hours this is a
question that I asked myself when at my
first job out of college I was talking
about suffering and my desk was in fire
exit
it was completely illegal you know slept
under the desk the whole nine yards and
don't regret a minute of it but I was a
Technical Sales guy outbound sales guys
we had inside sales outside sales and my
job was to close
with CTOs and ceos for multi-million
dollar data storage systems at that
point storage area networks fibre
channel and what I realized at one point
was that all of the seasoned sales guys
who were doing far better than I was
doing we're making phone calls between
9:00 and 5:00
those were the office hours and I said
well I'm clearly not doing an effective
job mimicking them what if I did the
opposite for 48 hours it's a very
recoverable experiment but if it doesn't
work then I can always go back to what I
was doing doing the opposite met making
my calls between let's just say 6:30 and
8:30 and then 5:30 to 7:00 7:30 and it
was just a hypothesis maybe I can get a
hold of the people I need to get a hold
of more effectively when the gatekeepers
aren't there and that's exactly what
happened and I started booking more
meetings and closing more deals than
than the majority of the guys in the
company and it was just from asking that
question what if I did the opposite for
48 hours and you can apply that to many
many things and some of the others would
be Bob this is one I asked in 2004 if I
had a gun against my head and could only
work two hours per week what would I do
I know it's impossible what would I do
and that type of ludicrous question was
necessary to break my thinking patterns
and test stress test my own assumptions
of what was possible and you find that
that is a learn about also if you want
to learn how to have more confidence
check of my 254 series they're free the
links aren't in description below a lot
of the anxiety that we feel is actually
due to using words that are not defined
very well now a self discipline it comes
from the self it comes from you from day
one I just I never tried to hide that I
was the girl in
my apartment with the red backpack rule
number three know how to sell with Mark
Cuban fails cures all lots of companies
come in and say I have a great idea or I
have a company and we've got some sales
but we only need to do this and we only
need to do that and you talk to them and
you talk to the entrepreneur and I'm
like why aren't you selling this is your
whole company there's never been a
company in the history of companies to
live to survive without sales and so I
think you know now as more and more
people watch Shark Tank they're seeing
it but if you can't sell if it's your
company and you can't sell you're not
going to be in business long
particularly when you're starting up and
it's just you and sales is not something
you can give to somebody else and say
okay I'm just gonna hire salespeople
Michael humectant that guy I told you
about that fired me
for hand him the check he was the guy
who wouldn't see he was the CEO and
owner he would never sell he thought he
could just bring us in and sell it and
the company failed after what you got a
sell rule number four
start small think big with Sara Blakely
thanks was profitable from the first
month that I was in business and I I'm
in of the belief system for me and my
journey to start small think big and
scale fast and a lot of people want to
start big and think big and oftentimes
get ahead of themselves and and that can
end wildly successfully but it can also
cause a lot of problems and you dilute
yourself down a lot and you know then
you have a lot of other people you're
answering to so that just was the
journey that I took you know I mean is I
started it with five grand I've never
had any outside funding and whatever
money I made from selling Spanx I just
put back into the business I love that
start small think big and rule number
five the last one before our very
special bonus clip is be honest with
James Hetfield what are you most credit
with the success the ongoing the
continued success in Metallica no but
there's one thing that is really the
core of that honesty for sure honesty
whether it's in a some kind of monster
movie worth of music or a live show
being honest you know
at the show last night the one intro
ends intro to one I go out and I start
playing fade to black it's like what and
me realizing and getting that wave of
like shame like oh my god you're an
idiot and they're like alright just
laugh at it cuz it's kind of funny and
what else are you gonna do if you know
and then start this one song and then
later talk about it
so being honest about it is so freeing
being honest with each other with
ourselves
you know we're 53 what's it look like
what are we gonna do how long can we
tour you know what's gonna you know how
can we stay healthy and happy you know
so being honest with each other now I've
got a special bonus tip from Tim Ferriss
on how to find the right mentors that I
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the three-point
landing questions let's go from just
watching the video to taking action here
we go question number one what do you
need to take more ownership of in your
life number two what thinking pattern do
you need to break this week and number
four where can you just start small on
your big idea very frequently we'll ask
someone for instance what advice would
you give to a 30 year old just getting
started here in your industry what is
the best advice you would give and just
as important I think you should ask what
advice should that person ignore or what
is the worst advice that you hear
repeated often in your industry what is
the conventional wisdom that you
disagree with those type of questions
give you a not to do list and it is what
you don't do that provides the space for
what you can do anyone who says you
should do this the way I did it without
any caveats should be maybe ignored
in many cases but certainly viewed with
suspicion the the type of mentors who
tend to be the most helpful or those who
don't necessarily give you an answer
but they give you a better way of
finding that answer I'm leaving my
second job I want to start my own
company what should I do and they say
well I can't tell you what you should do
because I don't have enough information
which is a huge credibility point in my
mind that they have the awareness to say
that and they said but if I were in your
position here's how I might think
through it and so look for mentors who
don't necessarily give you answers but
who walk you through the process of how
they might think about making the proper
decision given all of your particulars
and I think that's what in my experience
separates a mediocre or decent mentor
from a great mentor
if you want to learn how billionaires
think check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there as much as possible look for the
job that you would take if you didn't
need a job I mean you know don't
sleepwalk through life but don't don't
say it's all gonna be great